the glitter and glamour of the golden
globes the hollywood foreign press
association's annual awards blowout was
one of the film world's favorite events
until that is an enormous controversy
blew up over the hfpa's
near total lack of racial diversity and
questionable ethical behavior among its
members that sent a-list stars fleeing
sponsors opting out and its broadcaster
dropping the ceremony like a hot rock so
for 2022 no red carpet no celebrity
audience no host no tv show and not even
an internet live stream if you weren't
an actual member of the association or
one of its few invited guests the
viewing experience of this year's golden
globes looked a lot like this
part of me feels so bad for them because
they can't quite seem to get on the
right foot they can't as james brown
would say they can't get on the good
foot you know what i mean the hfpa has
announced changes including expanding
its membership just like the academy of
motion pictures did after the oscars so
white outrage in 2015. with studios
including warner media netflix and
amazon cutting ties some in the industry
think the organization's days are
numbered there's been so much damage to
the organization's reputation and the
membership and this and that that i'm
not so sure they can recover from this
as for the awards themselves the power
of the dog won best picture drama sort
of a lonesome place out here pete unless
he get in the swing of things nicole
kidman in being the ricardo's won best
actress sorry
i got lost for a second
and the best actor in a drama award went
to will smith for his role in king
richard
golden globe's non-ceremony which
happened at this swanky hotel behind me
was more bad news for the film
industry's traditional business model
with a new survey showing nearly half of
all pre-pandemic moviegoers are not
buying tickets anymore and some of them
will be staying home for good rob
reynolds al jazeera los angeles